critical physicist Gen 11 maps out the
boundaries in her new book how the
universe got its spots taken from a
series of unsent letters to her mother
the book argues that the cosmos is both
endless and finite miss Levinson Lee at
the California Institute of Technology
for an hour so one of the I guess great
questions of our time and in terms of
Sciences the origins of the universe
where did it all begin how did it get
started what was there before the Big
Bang all that stuff the nature of space
and time I do think that there is an
interesting literary and cultural
phenomenon that I call scientism that
the literary agent Jon Brockman calls
the third culture you know see peace
knows two cultures the sciences and the
humanities and arts they don't talk to
each other's is a BIST between the two
Brockman calls the third culture this
sort of new scientistic culture books
about science books about nature books
about the world that if you want to be
considered a literate person you want to
be part of the the sort of culture of
letters you really need to read science
books because that's where the action is
now and that that's bridge that gap if
you if you want to know what's going on
you have to have read Stephen Hawking or
Stephen Jay Gould or Richard Dawkins or
Ed Wilson or whatever these are the the
kinds of new myths for our time that
tell the big story that offer really a
complete worldview as complete as any
worldview could be satisfying to those
of us who don't need the other religious
based or non secular based worldviews
and and I think a contribution to that
is this this book how the universe got
its spots which is one of the great
titles you can have for I think a
lecture in a book Janna Levin is a
cosmologists that studies this stuff and
I I do think in terms of calling science
the myth I don't mean it's not true I
mean mythos and it's a story it's a
great story but it's a lot more
interesting story than most of these
other mythic stories because it's always
changing it's not just being
reinterpreted based on the language but
reinterpreted based on evidence
and so nothing changes faster it seems
like in cosmology it's the universe is
expanding it's gonna expand and stop no
it's not it's gonna expand forever is to
expand faster slower whatever and it's
constantly changing and so Janna wrote
this book to sort of bring to everybody
in the form of letters to her mom
explaining what she does for a living
because parents would like to know that
what do you're gonna do what and they
pay for this how are you gonna make
anyway she has advanced fellow in the
Department of applied mathematics and
theoretical physics at Cambridge
University I made the mistake of
announcing we have a we have a Brit
coming to America she's not she's
actually from Chicago who works in
Cambridge University holds a PhD from
the Massachusetts Institute of
Technology and worked previously at the
Canadian Institute for Theoretical
astrophysics and at the Center for
particle astrophysics at UC Berkeley so
please help me welcome dr. Janna Levin
we've been a little slow with technical
things tonight so yes I could be
launched to the moon myself yeah I
didn't realize we're all skeptics
recently I was talking to a woman who
has a psychic parrot who I really wanted
to go I wanted to fly to New York to
talk to the psychic parrot and she said
you know no you're bad Energy's gonna
psyche the bird out and she really
didn't want me coming but she said she
had to have the birds interest but she
made these great videos where she would
look at magazines and the bird would
guess what she was looking at it was
really some Bettina parrots they sound
exactly like their owners so it really
sounded like she was making the bird
sounds it was not very believable well
down to even more ethereal things I'm
going to be talking about whether the
universe is infinite or finite and this
is a branch of research I was interested
in for a couple of years I can't say I
worked on it forever or that I'll work
on it in the future it's something that
kind of drifts in and out of my
interests and it's not a question we've
answered yet it's something that we're
looking at both from particle physics
you know the physics of the smallest
microscopic laws of the universe and
physics on the absolute largest scale
we're trying to to meet in the middle
and try to understand something about
the entire shape of the universe we live
in
so I'm going to begin somewhere I was
gonna say at the beginning but of course
it's never really the beginning it's
Michael said it's just a story that
keeps growing and keeps evolving so I'll
begin somewhere in the middle of the
story it was really after Einstein that
we started to be able to formulate this
question and everyone's heard of
Einstein but sometimes people don't
really know everything that he did they
know about the theory of relativity and
one of the great things I Stein did as
he said space and time are not absolute
things that just exist out there in the
universe
they're mutable evolving changing things
now his theory is not a complete theory
it it has certain limitations and one of
the limitations is that it assumes that
the universe is infinite and I'll be
talking about how we tried to take one
step beyond Einstein and we try to ask
the question what if the universe were
finite how
we know this what kind of math would we
use how would we visualize it most or
talks going to be about trying to
visualize it because I think as Michael
said when we speak in Greek I think it
would be very boring if I said here
saying that Jamie and him Yuma pod mod
gamma paisa I won't be talking in the
language of the mathematics I'll be
mostly visually trying to reconstruct
what the world could look like so I
liked in the assumption that the
universe is infinite to the old
assumption that European explorers had
that the earth was flat and if you think
about it they knew it wasn't really flat
they knew that there were mountains and
hills and valleys but they kind of
thought well you know the earth can't go
on forever
it can't be infinite they didn't really
think of it as being infinite instead
they said it must have just an ugly edge
and they imagined that if you took a
boat and you left I forgotten where we
are we in California where in California
if you left and you traveled in the
Pacific in a boat I've been in so many
places lately and you just went in a
straight line you got off your boat but
you kept going a straight line you
walked you got into a car and you never
turned left you never turned right you
never went backwards you would
eventually come back to California again
so it turns out that the I have a point
the earth doesn't have some ugly edge
nor is it infinite it's actually a
smooth surface
it's edgeless it's completely finite and
and even though it's finite it has no
edge its unbound it's bounded bounded
but edgeless that's the trick we want to
make an entire universe in the same way
we want to say if the universe is not
infinite does that mean you will just
travel in a spaceship and eventually
come to the end of space itself or the
universe just ends and that's very ugly
we don't want to do that that would not
be a positive extension of Einstein's
theory that would be ugly so what we try
to do is we try to say well what if the
entire cosmos was like the earth if it
was finite bounded but edgeless and what
would that universe look like it was
discovered by by engineers Penzias and
Wilson when they were working for Bell
Labs they had this radio dish that they
were thinking radio dish that they were
trying to clean out to get a better
telephone signal I'm not sure
works but what they discovered was the
light left over from the Big Bang they
discovered the echo that last note that
little hum that's static that surrounds
us in all directions wherever you look
there's remnant from the origin of the
universe one of the most important
discoveries for cosmology of the last
century for sure for sure
and this picture here do I made this
flat if you imagine launching the
satellite into space that looks over the
entire sky it will actually make a
spherical picture of the sky so there
was a satellite launched called Kobe
which looked all over the entire sky for
this radiation left over from the Big
Bang now they actually got a map of a
sphere but if you cut it open and lay it
flat it makes this kind of oval shape
this is just - it's just like taking a
map of the earth and flattening it out
onto a flat sheet of paper I think from
now on I'm gonna reap lot this
spherically nobody all cosmologists look
at this and this oval shapes and now as
I'm standing in front of you I'm
wondering why we do that it's so that we
can see the front and the back at the
same time that's what it is if you have
a spear and you just you can only look
at one side at a time and that's a
problem so here it's projected as we can
see just like looking at the entire
surface of the earth at once and these
are little hot and cold spots left over
from the Big Bang little tiny
temperature differences and I liken
these to in animals birthmarks mammalian
coat patterns it turns out that in these
hot cold spots it's going to be the
secret of the shape of the universe and
there is a trend in mathematical biology
where the biologists try to understand
how the mammal goddess spots how the
leopard got its spots and it's realize
it's a very similar problem you're
trying to understand how you get these
birthmarks on an animal with a funny
shape and the shape and size of the
animal as its developing it's critical
to the distribution of marks on its back
now if you imagine that we were little
tiny fleas living on the Leopards back
if you were so so so small smaller than
a flea we might think that this one spot
that we were living on was the whole
animal or that the animal was infinite
we might not know that in fact
it's a finite animal but we're just
small relative to the variation in its
color and if we're able to if we're big
enough to map out a larger region we
might start to realize oh no this this
animal goes from spots to light or like
a zebra from black to white and we might
only know if we're large enough to see
that far and from the pattern on that on
the animals back we could deduce the
shape of the animal and this is similar
in the universe by looking for these hot
and cold spots we're asking can we
deduce the entire shape of the universe
now we don't know yet but there are
satellites being launched there's one
launched last year called math and
there's a satellite proposed in the next
couple years called Planck surveyor and
from the details of these satellite
observations of this radiation left over
from the Big Bang we think we might be
able to reconstruct the shape of space
so although I should say those
satellites aren't launching for that
reason they're launching because they're
more interested in the curvature they're
more interested to find out if we live
on something that that convex mirror or
if we live in a flat universe but we're
piggybacking on those experiments to say
well you might as well go the whole way
and figure out if we can see all the way
around the cosmos these are just I'm
just gonna kind of flick through these
pictures these are hypothetical
mathematical pictures that generate us a
lot of my collaborators you see lots of
really interesting people have worked on
this and you can sum their names my book
cuz I'll miss somebody and they'll be
really mad you can sort of see that the
pattern starts to emerge when I have
different we lived in some funny shaped
space don't worry about things actually
have a space the pattern and the hot and
cold spots would change as a space
changed and these are sort of encoded
patterns that we might see in the shape
of space that's just kind of a little
zoo and we go through by predicting we
go through mathematically trying to
hypothetically reconstruct what the sky
might look like if it had these
different shapes but at the end of the
day what we really need to do is look
out in the sky it's like it's like
trying to to idealize a leopard and then
match it up perfectly we don't really
want to do that we want to go to the zoo
and
I mean I look by eye and say oh there's
me for there's a leopard there's an
offense there's an anteater so I think
getting to the claws it's clear that
there's this cosmic slew of
possibilities the reason why we don't
know where we live isn't just because oh
we can't observe that we also
theoretically don't have a prediction we
don't theoretically have a prediction
for the entire shape of space and it is
possible that the theories will come
back as we plow along more and more I
don't think I'm using my conclusion page
so that's great and as we plow along
more and more that that will start to
say well maybe the universe really is
infinite you know and and so people
often ask me why do you believe the
universe is finite and it's not about
belief it's not that I believe one thing
or the other thing it's that there seems
something untenable about an infinite
universe nah I'll just end with that I
think if you imagine an infinite
universe it means that there's an
infinite number of galaxies in that
universe there's an infinite number of
planets in those infinite number of
galaxies and one of those planets has
got to look infinitely close to the
earth in fact there's an infinite number
of them they're looking for close to
Earth and then there's an infinite
number of rooms right now somewhere in
space where we're all having this
conversation and it starts to seem
really absurd no it's not actually
impossible but it is it starts to smell
is something rotten and you know in a
it's maybe we are so arrogant we'd like
to believe we're such individual said
it's not possible but I actually think
what's worse than that I find it really
hard to believe that somewhere else in
the cosmos there's exactly this
distribution of people having exactly's
conversation and then somewhere else
there's a rim slightly different where
peoples made slightly different choices
you know slightly different mistakes of
slightly different lives playing out so
it hints that maybe we should be
thinking differently and so we take this
as a piece in the puzzle in the meantime
and so we have a better theory beyond
Einstein it's or until we actually have
an observation thanks and I'd like to
take questions
I'm gonna I'm going to try to repeat the
questions for the so everyone can hear
it but if I forget just remind me
question on the front here and then I'm
sorry next
I'll cease to be uniform or something or
she would have set the ball rolling
explorers galaxies
is there anything that would neither a
spherical or a saddle shaped space I am
would affect which anise pots of god or
Halloween yeah back but so the question
is is there some way that the the shape
of space whether it was flat or
spherical or negatively curved what it
would affect these spots and how would
it affect the spots edges and yeah
that's that's exactly how we did it
would affect the shape and size of of
the [ __ ] of these temperature
differences and again back to the
analogy of the leopard it turns out that
if it's finite just to harp on on this
point that because of the geometry of it
being like a cylinder it actually
determines the pattern and if it was
more tapered like the tail you'll often
see stripes drawn out so it's a matter
mathematically have solved its formally
called solving the laplacian on a finite
space you're solving a wave equation on
a curved space with finite boundary
conditions and it absolutely does affect
the shape of space and if you can think
of it as also a waterway so you can
imagine having water waves in a funny
shaped pool or with funny boundaries and
it will certainly affect the pattern of
waves and that's really what these are
are these are hot and cold waves running
through the whole cosmos they're not
considered to be that independent they
there are peaks and valleys in a wave
that ran through in some sense the space
okay that's another question
denying admittedly unprovable hypotheses
of singularities appreciating the faith
bang similar to the hypotheses of
singularities within black holes so the
question is I seem to be denied the
absolute definitive existence of
singularities the in the Big Bang and
also in black holes so first just to
describe what a singularity a
singularity is when space-time is curved
so intensely it's actually infinitely
curved and that's what they think
happens in the centers of black holes
and that's what happens in the Big Bang
and it's I don't think anybody really
believes in singularities I think they
think it's a mark of Einstein's theory
breaking down so the theory describes an
incredible curvatures so a black hole is
being kind of a funnel and space is
incredibly strong curvature but it goes
to the point where it actually allows it
to become infinite and even Einstein
wanted to believe nature would protect
us from the formation of these infinite
regions of curvature that they were
somehow impossible in a valid physical
theory again what he was doing was
rejecting infinity so I mean also said
something really funny he said only two
things are infinite the universe and
human stupidity and I'm not sure about
the former he said and and neither am I
sure
so so this what we're doing which I call
I in the book I think I said it's like a
dead man scratching Clues in the dirt
you know that's what that's what the
theory is doing it's pointing to its own
failure it's saying I can no longer
handle regions of this extreme curvature
I can't tell you the answer but I'm
breaking down you know this is where the
theory is no longer any good and as we
try to do quantum gravity theories as we
try to make some kind of union between
physics on the smaller scales and
physics on the larger scales the the
aspiration is that those kinds of
infinities will go away that is
certainly one of the hearts which is why
also that the initial being Big Bang
will be rewritten
as will the size of the space that
creates in those early moments will be
rewritten by a theory that has not yet
really come to fruition dabble doubt in
string theory dabbled at in quantum
any theories she's gonna move out in the
room and he had their questions
oh you June well I keep tapping the mic
I should just launch right the battery
went dead when did you guys lose me how
far back should I try to take a question
in the meantime I know you've got one
right now just okay it was a customer
over here okay maybe an ask the question
go ahead earlier that universe would
imply an infinite amount of matter and I
was wondering could it be possible to
have an infinitely large universe with a
finite amount of matter in it just a lot
of space it's possible but it's really
it's not the most attractive solution so
the question was I seem to imply that an
infinite universe implied an infinite
amount of matter and would it be
possible to have an infinite universe
with a finite amount of matter
it isn't really possible unless they
make the universe really not at all very
symmetric and that's actually much
harder to do than it is to just make the
universe finite in the first place that
is mother nature it doesn't care if this
math is hard for us originally does
she's gonna do what's easiest you know
water rolls down hills even that's a
very complicated thing to calculate it
doesn't take a smoother path to make it
easier on us and so so that's what I
mean by it's easier to make a universe
it means that presumably the laws of
physics imply it would be a lot easier
take a lot less noodling and fine-tuning
and a degree of precision to make a
universe which was finite but had matter
more or less roughly evenly distributed
throughout it to create a space that's
infinite with matter just in the center
is very very awkward very very awkward
in fact I just I'm not sure if you could
do it you know
what appears to be the edge at a
specific point or is it um that's an
interesting question if you imagine the
but first of all the turtle does not
experience an edge at all and and in
some of these spaces you can redraw the
shape if you if you're drawing it around
a different Center okay the edge is
meaningless it's just a matter of what
would you trace out if you try to map
the space let's say by blowing up a
balloon if you blow up a balloon and
you're standing in one location you
might trace out a different shape than
if you're standing at another location
and so it's really emphasizing the point
that this boundary does not exist okay
and again it's kind of like cutting open
the earth again in a way you know it's
not a great analogy but I'll use it
anyway
you know you might draw the seams
differently each time you cut it open
the earth this really doesn't have the
edge it doesn't exist understanding what
the universe is expanding into and this
is expanding into existing spacers are
creating new spaces it's enlarging
where's it going
yeah this is one of those questions I
think Oh
the question was thinks the question was
I have trouble imagining what the
universe expands into and where is it
going
I think the Cloutier questions he said
of where and as soon as there's aware
there's space and if I can draw a point
to where it is that space exists it
might as well be part of the universe if
there really is no space it's
meaningless to ask the question if I
imagine flatland I'm looking at it from
the third dimension so I'm assuming the
third dimension really exists and that
you can point to it and for some reason
the Flatlanders just can't point to it
but but we know it's there now you can
imagine that third dimension really
doesn't exist there is no third
dimension there's no us there's no
three-dimensional creatures it is just
those 2d and that space can expand in
the sense that two points on it will
move further away from each other and
all two points on it will continue to
move away from each other it's not
spending into anything and so that's
really what the whole game of space-time
is based on that's why a lot of these
visual aids are deceptive and we have to
really rely on the formal mathematics
some spaces have to be embedded in other
certain larger dimensional spaces but
most do not the other question that's
often asked is what happened before the
Big Bang so I'm gonna preempt it I
always get a say and it's a very similar
question the question is er really was
no time if that if that model is right
and the universe had a beginning and
that's a big if then there really was no
time and if you think about time time is
change it is the clicking of a talk it
is the the movement of a hand from one
location to another location if none of
those events ever occur if if clocks
aren't built
if cells aren't decaying if a breath
isn't exhaled there is really no meaning
to the notion of time it's not a
meaningful question an instant eternity
you'd have to it you'd have to have a
build a clock to measure the difference
okay so
take another question from let me just
go further after sick of it back there
yes how would you describe a dimension
like the diameter of the universe mm-hmm
if hi universe it could be conceived of
as a spherical shape right well so the
question is how would you describe the
diameter of the universe for instance if
the universe has spherical shape how
would you describe the diameter ature to
me but but describe but usually I think
what you mean is how what we need in
that is a relative scale we need to know
how big is it relative to something how
big is that scale relative to the size
of an atom or the size of a galaxy or
the distance light has traveled since
the Big Bang and that's how we measure
the the size of space now we we haven't
we haven't really measured any size to
space because so far we can't really be
sure if it's curved or not or if it's
infinite or not we really don't know the
answer that question if it was at least
curved even if it looked infinite we'd
be able to say how curved is it relative
to the distance light has had to travel
since the Big Bang and we can make some
relative comparison between those two
things that's and that's really how
we'll be measuring it relative to the
distance light he's traveled so question
over here
and evolve a little barkas the customers
what keeps pace from within a cluster of
galaxies from expanding well space on a
larger scale expanses it turns out that
the local gravitational pull of the
organized matter is more important than
the global gravitational expansion and
it's just a matter of comparing which
which predominates which is stronger do
you know there's a Woody Allen joke you
know he's forget what movie had said but
he doesn't want to do its homework
because the universe is expanding as
much as you live in Brooklyn you know
Brooklyn is not expanding and that's
really the truth of it you know Brooklyn
is not expanding on the earth where
what's much more important than the
expansion of space is a gravitational
pull of the earth that's what we're
combating every day we don't even know
the universe is expanding until we do
some pretty ambitious astronomical
experiments and it really wasn't until
recently that we learned that so that
seems to take over on a larger scale
when the global clustering of mass is
more important on a smaller scale back
in the Big Bang is generally described
as an instantaneous and I wonder how
much truth is there to that it seems to
defy common sense everything else in
nature is a process so the question is
is is that the Big Bang is usually
portrayed as an instantaneous event and
how realistic is that since everything
else in nature tends to be more of a
process I think that again this is
because of the limitation of the current
working theory and and in fact some
people say that with quantum gravity we
won't have sort of point like anything
we won't have instance in time or point
like matter everything will be sort of
relational processes that is how we will
fundamentally understand everything that
there are that we will come to think
that there aren't there's no actual
particles in the universe that they are
just events and we perceive these events
to be organized particles or or on some
large scale they begin to look like that
so when we rewrite the story of the Big
Bang presumably it's going to be quite
different although we know pretty well
what happens very very small
a second after the Big Bang now 10 to
the minus 35 seconds after the Big Bang
our theories are doing ok 10 to the
minus 3 I mean that's such a small
number but I mean also people say well
what does that number mean against the
idea of building a clock you couldn't
possibly build a clock back then it's
really hard to say what that's what that
means those units are human units their
units that we use because of the the Sun
and the Earth's rotation and the lunar
cycles this is how we've invented years
minutes seconds it's really hard to
understand what that scale really means
back then but nonetheless the point is
is that we understand pretty pretty
early on what it's looking like you know
before that is a Pandora's box
so the Christmas is anyone ever tried to
determine the sound and the decibel so
well from the Big Bang it's not as crazy
as it sounds actually the point is is
that a sound not to imply it was
sounding crazy I sound it's a wave in
air or water or some medium okay so to
make sound you need to cause
oscillations in some medium now the
universe when it's first existing and
these small small small moments there
hasn't been enough time to create a
physical oscillation across matter in
fact we don't really know what matter
looks like in terms of quarks in the
plasma
it's a really crazy crazy plasma however
one of the earlier question and map of
these experiments look into the sky what
they're trying to measure is acoustic
Peaks but they're really measuring a
sound waves in the in the medium of the
universe in the matter of the universe
not in the first instance but after say
three hundred thousand years into the
universe's life and and it's these
oscillations that are causing again
little hot and cold spots in this
radiation left over from the Big Bang so
these the radiations there in this
matter sloshing and it causes it to
Doppler shift to heat up a little
another direction so in a sense I
suppose you could probably turn that
into a sound I've never really thought
about it that I'm way in the back over
here yeah yeah it's guys harm way up but
he's looking behind so the president is
is there any mathematical credence to
the Big Crunch the idea that one day the
universe will contract mathematically
yeah it's there's there's there's
certainly perfectly viable solutions to
the theories we have available that say
the universe is expanding it will
eventually stop expanding and rhe
contract it's just like throwing a ball
up in the air it will eventually stop
and then come crashing back down and if
it does we collapse it will go back
towards what's called a Big Crunch over
on the home movie of the universe
backwards and what happens thereafter we
don't really know what it bounced back
out would it continue to just oscillate
bouncing and we'd have history after
history where the entire cosmos was
erased and started over again it's a
perfectly valid solution now again these
are all pieces in a wider puzzle and
until we've made further theoretical
steps I don't think we have any idea
which we can't say one's right or I
believe in this one all we can do is say
it's worth pursuing this it's worth
pursuing the possibility that there will
be a Big Crunch in a series of
oscillations and that in fact the
universe didn't have one big bang event
it's infinitely old it's had an infinite
number of the Big Bang events in the
past and we're just one incarnation and
the true history of the cosmos and we're
just somewhere in the middle of an
infinite series of course if it's really
infinite these mystics we know the
middle you know you can always slide it
around
what same question everything
with this with it tell you are not
whether universe is infinite yes it
would actually if we could predict the
customers if you could predict when the
Big Crunch would start would you be able
to say something about whether it's
infinite or finite I lied a little bit
there's one solution to Einstein's
theory that's completely predicted by
Einstein's theory as a possibility that
is in fact finite one solution one
solution only and in that model of the
universe the universe looks like a
three-dimensional sphere and it is
completely finite and it will have this
Big Crunch it will it will expand to
some maximum and then we collapse and so
if that's what we find out then if that
in fact the universe is everywhere
positively curved like a sphere it's a
three-dimensional sphere then we should
be able to predict when the Big Crunch
would happen and we should be able to
tell the size of the space indirectly
now I should also say that most people
believe that we live in such a small
patch it's like living on the earth and
not realizing it's curved and we don't
realize it's curved because we live on
such a small patch we were standing on a
basketball we would know it was curved
right because the earth is so huge
relative to the human scale that we
think that people made the mistake of
thinking that was flat so similarly you
wonder how small a patch do we occupy in
a finite universe and that's why a lot
of people and I might include myself in
this believe that even if the universe
is actually finite and that's
theoretically a better way for the
universe to initiate we might never see
it and so it's really a matter of doing
quantum gravity I'm looking at looking
at the small secrets in terms of trying
to get the big picture
so even when people say for instance the
universe is flat they don't really mean
that it's flat they just mean we live in
such a small local patch that it looks
effectively flat and they're not willing
to say what's beyond that way in the
back over there
your spots they're actually an image
taken by the Colby telescope or the Coby
satellite of the universe at 300,000
years and after the Big Bang correct yes
sir and then the spots represent
temperature and density variations
that's right and that they're the seeds
of what are the galaxies are today okay
well I didn't say that's you've been
studying up okay okay now one last thing
is when they took the photograph are
they taking the photograph of the
temperature at like three degrees above
absolute zero
yeah the the temperature today I said
it's very very few know the universe was
once incredibly unfathomably hot and
it's been expanding for so many billions
of years that it's actually quite cold
now it's three degrees above absolute
zero as the temperature that they're
looking at that that there is this cool
echo everywhere this one temperature and
these tiny hot and cold spots are very
very very tiny variations above that
temperature there there one part in a
hundred thousand different from the
average it's very small that's why these
experiments are so sophisticated so just
I forgot to repeat the question but you
get the gist now what was the question
was the question was just reiterating
that the the Kobe experiment looked at
the radiation that was left over from
the Big Bang it's looking at it at an
age of 300 thousand years into the
universe's of life these little colored
spots are slight hot and cold spots
about that average temperature and
they're caused by variations in curves
in space and variations in density and
the point that was added on was that
these variations and density and curves
in space ultimately see galaxy formation
and that's also believed to be quite
true that that there's no way you know
the universe is carry with lots of
matter whizzing around everywhere and
somehow it organizes in clumps into
galaxies and clusters of galaxies and
very very fascinating the ordered
structures did we just lose this again
yeah I heard it go off that time sorry
how are we for time anyway
okay so so the states so those little
variations also form the structures of
galaxies as it's done how did I lose it
oh it's what you do oh there yeah okay
so the question was what's my personal
preferences universe flat and curved or
infinite or finite and you know all
universes are created equal in my mind
you know the Orwells store you know
animal farm but some universes are
worried about than others I think that a
finite universes are much more elegant
way for the university to explain itself
in a way it's not that I I don't believe
it one way or the other if the data
comes back if the theories come back and
and convince me otherwise I will be
happy to abandon that notion but I think
a lot of times what you're doing is
saying this doesn't sound right it's
worth taking that step it's worth
pursuing the possibility that in fact
the universe is finite now I do think
that that if gravity if space-time is
really to be unified with the theory of
physics on the small scales then gravity
space time all these things are really
just different expressions of matter now
it's hard to believe but they're really
like different phases of water you know
ice and steam are ultimately really the
same thing they look totally different
but they're both h2o and the idea
similarly that gravity is really the
same thing as matter it just looks
really different it's a different phase
of matter and if that's true I would
like it to be born finite I think that
would be a more elegant story and also
when you look at things like string
theories and theories of quantum gravity
that try to go beyond Einstein's theory
it's very natural to talk about finite
spaces you know astronomers thought this
work was incredibly esoteric the
particle physicists didn't bat an eye
absolute everyday occurrence for them to
talk about ten extra dimensions that
were topologically compact and rolled in
on themselves and had funny shapes
so it really depends what community
you're in how much how heretical it
seems back there question the bareback
uh you could that God asked her ready
the question was what was the universe
expanding into ready to think we already
addressed anyone want to see if they
studied well it's a test it's a quiz so
the questions would answer is really
that it's not expanding into anything
that it's just space itself see any
other story with here in the middle yeah
a couple quick questions one of them I
thought you were gonna explain the why
there is such a pattern like that could
be discovered and why it's not uniform
this background radiation and I'd
appreciate if we can kind of elaborate
on that a little bit and the second one
can you tell already from as rough an
image Kobe has provided that there is
none of the type of symmetries that
you're looking for I'm coming from Kobe
so the question was could I say
something about the pattern that Kobe
already observed why it isn't completely
uniformed so Kobe was that experiment
that was launched over ten years ago
which I first showed up at the hot and
cold spots and and can we use Kobe to
look for the shape of space so tend to
the first question the pattern actually
looks pretty uniform there are hot and
cold spots but they seem to be very very
very evenly distributed throughout the
cosmos
this is one of the great mysteries
actually what it seems to say is the
temperature of the universe is this two
point seven three degrees above absolute
zero but it's like that in every single
direction in the sky and the only
variation are these one part in a
hundred thousand slightly hotter
slightly colder now if you were an
archaeologist and you found evidence
that there were ancient civilizations
that he thought lived at opposite poles
but were speaking the same language to
one part in 100,000 he wouldn't think
this was a coincidence right you'd think
they must once have been communicating
they must have shared a language would
come to understand each other and
similarly by looking at this
finding that in fact the sky is so
similar across a vast expanse of what
looks like nearly 30 billion light years
that space must have once been in causal
contact
they must have averaged out like the
temperature of this room comes to some
kind of average and the theory which
tries to explain that is called
inflation it's a very important paradigm
for how we understand how it could be
possible to start with the universe
which is very small and is now so vast
so huge and so smooth and this is one of
the important theories we're testing
with the future satellites now the
question about whether or not we can
measure the shape of space we can but
not well enough for instance you can ask
what if the universe was really this
funny parallelepiped this funny square
cube rather and and couldn't match the
Cobie data and it turns out it can you
try to fit this radiation in this small
square you try to generate the pattern
it would that would emerge by Jen again
jamming this balloon if you like in this
small box and it is consistent with Kobe
it says that if that's the case the
universe is maybe around half the size
of the observable of you know maybe 15
billion light years across as opposed to
30 billion light years across but it's
not proof of it's simply a consistency
so we there's been a lot of work on that
the Big Bang you singularity and also
you mentioned singularity with black
holes okay you have a Big Bang which
would have be a very massive black hole
I assume why haven't we observed any
little bangs and the Big Bang isn't
exactly a massive black hole they are
different they're singularities might
become especially different they are
different black holes don't emit
anything they don't emit lights they
don't reflect light that's why they're
black they're dark if there's a black
hole out in the Sun evaporate well so
Stephen Hawking is most famous for his
suggestion that black holes will in fact
evaporate the reason why it was such an
incredibly important idea was because it
seemed to theoretically impossible all
black holes were defined on the base
the fact that the absorbs matter and did
never never let it go again and every
mitad matter so what what Stephen
Hawking did is he combined that theory
with a theory of particle physics so he
combined two different theories of
physics to come to the understanding
that in fact if I looked at the quantum
level of what was going on around the
black hole I might find that black holes
evaporated that they emitted light or
particles rather and slowly evaporated
it's it's slower than the age of the
universe for most black holes it's not a
realistic process it was just formally a
very very important process certainly
not a way to observe black holes and
it's not gonna make them go away and I
forgot to repeat that question I'm
really sorry I just want to get a
distribution around the room it's
custard here I'm not skipping anywhere
I'll come back to your policy all right
so the question will now repeat the
question and the question was if the Big
Bang is similar to a black hole for both
singularities why don't we see any
little bangs around space and that's
because they are different so the black
hole it's not that the black hole and
the inside might be looking like a big
bang in other words if you fell through
a black hole you would never see this
universe again you would never see this
outside world again you would fall into
the black hole but you might come out in
a kind of Big Bang event to somewhere
else so there have been models where
they try to imagine sewing on the center
of a black Hall to a Big Bang event but
we can't see it because it's hidden
behind this dark exterior they'd like
balloons out somewhere else and again
this is just an idea there's no way it's
been proven and it might never be proven
but it's just something that people is
played with just remember back there
latest idea of this dark energy or
quintessence is and will the map probe
or the Planck Explorer help us determine
what what that quintessence or dark
energy actually is so the question was a
question about the dark energy otherwise
sometimes known as quintessence
contestants is a specific theory about
the dark energy and whether I think map
and Planck survey are these future
satellites will resolve that so the
answer to the last part is yes math and
Planck surveyor will hopefully tell us
at least whether or not the universe is
accelerating now the dark energy is this
very mysterious thing what happens is is
that we look out into space and we see
that not only is the universe expanding
it's actually getting faster and faster
and faster and this is done by looking
at a supernova that have that have
exploded stars that have died and
exploded very very far away that that by
studying the pattern of how the heat and
cool and the temperatures of the
supernova we can figure out how far away
they are and how fast they're moving
away from us and it looks to us like the
universe is getting faster and faster
and faster it's very unexpected turn of
events nobody would have said that I
think five years ago or ten years ago
and the only way we know how to drive
that expansion is which something called
dark energy and the reason why it's
called it dark is because we've never
seen it people probably heard of dark
matter and it's also because we've never
seen it it seems to be that the
curvature of space the expansion of
space is pointing to a universe where
over 90% of the constituents are things
we have never heard of or seen before so
whenever you hear this statement o
cosmology is solved it is the opposite
it is just the beginning we're gonna
have some numbers we're gonna know how
fast it's expanding with the curvature
is but this future satellites but we're
still gonna have no idea what's out
there and we seem to be this sort of
Dusty's sediment a very very small
fraction of what's out there not at all
common if this turns out to be correct
and so the big again big push is going
to be for particle physicists and
cosmologists to come together to
understand what fundamental matter and
energy could be so novel and so weird
and
there was a question here just can't
believe I finally picked you is the
curve will curve space appreciably and
light following it in the small distance
like that the 93 million miles between
the Earth and the Sun I say that because
I've noticed at the time of the half
moon if you draw a line from the top and
the bottom of the Terminator and enjoy
90 degrees of that it doesn't here's
it's not on that horizon
it doesn't that lion doesn't points it's
not it points above it and I wonder if
that if light could sure curve and
that's small space well I'm gonna answer
it slightly differently so the question
was would in the in the distance between
the Sun and the earth is the mass
basically of the objects in our solar
system strong is the mass of the objects
in our solar system strong enough to
curve space in any measurable way that's
another way of asking the question thank
you yeah well the only effect that I
need that well there's only a couple
that I know it's I don't think it's
trying to do anything like that but the
curve is strong enough to cause light to
bend so if you look at a star behind the
Sun it's it will make a very very very
small e
small deflection in its path to the
earth it won't just cut straight through
and and if you think about how you would
observe this it's incredibly difficult
because the Sun is blindingly bright how
are you gonna follow a little tiny
squirt of light from a distant star and
the only reason we can do it is because
there's a total eclipse and it just
happens coincidentally that the moon's
subtends the right size in the sky two
completely occult all the light from the
Sun and allow this sliver of light from
a distant star pasture and when this
experiments first performed you know
Einstein was congratulated and final and
his theory finally did improvement and I
don't really know what his remark oh is
it something to the effect of yeah well
would you expect he seemed pretty
confident he seems pretty confident
and there is also something about the
precession of mercury it has to do with
Mercury's spin where you can see the
curvature effects that that mercury spin
seems to process a bit and it's a purely
relativistic I don't think so I think I
think I think that's I'm not sure you
know I'm not so good with the planetary
stuff but I really don't think the
scales are just right all right yeah I
know but look at this guy even if there
are an infinite number of galaxies it's
still only be countable and they're just
his room and accountable infinity of
galaxies to repeat this room you're
saying if the universe is infinite we
would be able to count an infinite
number of galaxies was that the question
yes well the reason there's just two
percent there first of all we've only
been around for a short time and you
know if I tried to count an infinite
number of pennies I would only get to a
finite number in the history of my
lifetime and similarly these galaxies
have only been around for a finite time
and so only the ones close enough for
the light to reach us are accountable at
all let alone our own limitation it's a
classification you made it number theory
countable
yeah are you asking me if they're if
they're countable in the numbers theory
says 13 if they're comfortable not
necessarily I'm not I'm not a hundred
percent sure about that because some of
these spaces so accountable infinity has
to do with the Infinity itself is a
weird idea no counter was this great
genius mathematician he spent his late
years in a mental asylum needless to say
and he was the first one to really
really push the idea of infinity a lot
of people before him did not believe
infinity had any place even in
mathematics let alone in reality and
what he proved is not only are there
infinities for instance the natural
numbers 1 2 3 4 5 up to an infinite
number but some infinities are bigger
than others you know
and and that's where he got really
clever and one of the the smallest
infinity I think is the countable
infinity it's related to the size of the
natural numbers one two three four five
it can be put into one one alignment
with those numbers it's it's not the
biggest infinity imaginable there could
be a bigger infinity and I'm not a
hundred cents sure depending on the
shape of space if it's countable I I'm
not I'm not a hundred in sure it's not
but I wouldn't leap to the conclusion
that it's countable if you look at a
negatively curved space you can see that
there is a certain proliferation of size
in a sense as you get further and
further away a lot of these pieces have
for instance chaotic properties and
peculiar things which are related to
exponential growth of possibilities it's
not 100% obvious to me that countable I
think I stumped you out of has too many
more in that question so the question is
why in string theory is it necessary
that for there to be ten or eleven
dimensions instead of three there are
some string theories I think now which
are strictly three-dimensional with the
extra dimension of time 3 plus 1 3 plus
1 dimensional originally it had to do
with curing odd behavior in the theory
it was perfect it was a purely
mathematical and formal glitch that if
they didn't do that they wouldn't get
they had to what's called renormalized
ok actually was an anomaly thing I think
it had to do with the anomalies so it
was in order to get certain glitches out
of the theory it just happened that if
you made it in extra dimensions it works
now the reason why that's intuitively at
least plausible is because in string
theory the suggestion is that matter is
not fundamentally a point particle if I
looked close enough that matter I would
see that it's actually individual
strings and that each atom each particle
is really a different mode or
vibrational mode on this one fundamental
type of string and and if you imagine a
string and the modes that string can
have the different ways it can make a
note if you like then the number of
dimensions it can wiggle into is
important and can change that spectrum
or the it can change the song as it can
play in a way so intuitively you can
imagine that the certain shape and size
of the extra dimension
we'll create different distributions and
particles in the universe and different
and will therefore be required to make
it look like the universe we live in
with the matter we live in you can let
me do this all night
one more question okay there's a
question the credit yep
the main problem seems to be combining
like quantum theory with relativity I
mean do you see some kind of new math
breakthrough that might do this or yeah
so the question is a lot of the areas
that I'm interested in I'm always saying
things like well we don't really know
yet it's just a piece of a puzzle and
the reason is it's the it's the
combination of Einstein's theory of
relativity with quantum theory and that
has never been smoothly sewn together
and the question was do I see foresee a
new branch of mathematics that's gonna
clear this up was that the question or a
new leap well there's a there's another
book by Lee Smolin called three roads to
quantum gravity where he talks about the
three tracks that people are taking to
really make leaps one of them is string
theory one of them is pure quantum
gravity or canonical quantum gravity and
another one I think was just classified
as or other I can't remember what the
other one is but more maybe more
philosophical looking into the
fundamental philosophies of quantum
theory and overthrowing that I I
personally you know don't know when when
I've been interested in working on this
I've been interested in doing stuff that
is I think fundamentally more of a
different direction so people are still
looking for a reductionist theory that
is one theory of everything and if you
write down this one mathematical
sentence you will be able to calculate
under the idea that nature takes the
path of least resistance all of the laws
of physics
everything about the Big Bang you know
down all the way through to biology if
you could and we might not be smart
enough to do that but it's theoretically
possible so I've been wondering what if
there isn't such one fundamental
centrist but many competing sentences if
you like and and the universe has an
ultimately reductionist but you had
complexity at the cord as a bit of
production
at the core something more like
complexity or chaos theory at the core
and I haven't made much progress but I
haven't I've just started we started
this thinking we brought the amazing
Randi and started work on skeptic
magazine so I guess today's our 10th
anniversary
second point we don't have many
celebrities and skeptics but our own
Julia Sweeney from Saturday Night Live
is here is Julia
somebody who saw her and God said
monologue on oxygen recently he's been
running she did her God monologue here
for us which is now being called when
they lost the faith story going to the
earth this next month
we have just four copies of Johnny's
book laughs tink of course you can pick
it up at Barnes & Noble and Amazon calm
the local bookstores and so I thank you
very much thank you
gen 11 is an advanced fellow in Applied
Mathematics and theoretical physics at
Cambridge University how the universe
got its spots diary of a finite time in
a finite space is published by Princeton
University Press on the web at PU P
Princeton dot edu